die Wohnungsnot wird zu einem der
größten sozialen Probleme dieses Landes
Baustellen liegen auf Eis und das hat
auch mit der Politik zu tun vieles wurde
unterschätzt einiges verschlimmert
Bauunternehmer fühlen sich allein
gelassen
die andere Regierung macht den Fehler
dass sie eigentlich die Nöte der Branche
ignoriert wir sind auf dem Weg in eine
Rezession und es wird immer noch
angenommen dass wir ein kleines dällchen
bekommen dass ich mit wenigen Maßnahmen
wiedergeben wird
nachdem die Politik das Thema jahrelang
vernachlässigt hat lädt nun der Kanzler
zum zweiten wohngipfel ein schließlich
war er als da ein großes
Wahlkampfversprechen gab
wenn ich sage was wir hinkriegen wollen
ist jedes Jahr 400.000 Wohnungen zu
bauen und damit nicht aufzuhören dann
ist das nicht unlösbar sondern etwas was
man anpacken muss liebe Freundinnen und
Freunde für ihn anpacken sollte das
klarer galwitz dafür wurde eigens wieder
ein Bundesbauministerium geschaffen sie
gilt als Scholz vertraute eins
kandidierten sie gemeinsam für den
spd-parteivorsitz und scheiterten
gescheitert ist auch ihr Versprechen
400.000 neue Wohnungen schon 2022 wurde
das deutlich verfehlt für die Zukunft
wird ein drastischer Rückgang
vorhergesagt nun der eh klar zwei
wichtige Verbände sagen ihre Teilnahme
am Gipfel ab so groß ist der Frust
das ist absurde Illusion zu glauben in
2023 werden 400.000 Wohnungen gebaut und
das schwingt bei uns auch noch nach das
nach dem letzten kanzlergipfel der
Kanzler und die bauministerin sich auf
den Rasen gestellt haben im Kanzleramt
und gesagt haben wir werden 2023 400.000
Wohnungen bauen ich fühlte mich total
veräppelt damals hatte der Ukraine Krieg
die Lage schon längst verschärft höhere
Baukosten teurere Energie und höhere
Zinsen als Kardinalsfehler gilt für
viele das Deutschland seitdem nicht
gegen steuere im Gegenteil schärfste
klimaschutzregeln dämmen und heizen
kostet
bemerkenswerterweise fordert heute die
bauministerin gaiwitz eine Abkehr von
weiteren energiesparvorschriften die
Grünen halten das für falsch dadurch
lösen wir alle anderen Probleme nicht
sondern verschieben einen Wesentliches
zu einem späteren Zeitpunkt es braucht
einen ganzen Blumenstrauß von Lösung und
es ist tatsächlich auch ein Märchen das
eben erneuerbare und sehr moderne
Heizung so teuer sind jeder der sich ein
bisschen damit auseinandersetzt wird das
Feststellen im Netz kursieren derweil
Videos über Schlangen bei der
Wohnungssuche die Lage dramatisch gerade
in Städten eine Konsequenz der
SPD-Fraktion sie will das Mietrecht
weiter verschärfen fordert einem
bundesweiten mietenstopp ihr
Positionspapier geht deutlich über die
Ampel Kompromisse hinaus der
Regierungspartner FDP hält das in dieser
Lage für falsch
Debatten und mietpreisbremsen sind im
Moment wirklich fehl am Platz wir müssen
Signale senden wie mehr gebaut wird
anstatt Signale dahin gehen zu senden
wie man Einkommen von Menschen die
bereit sind Geld zu investieren in den
Wohnungsbau nachhaltig beschneidet
sowieso weiß die SPD gerade beim
zuständigen FDP Justizminister auf
Granit Buschmann will die vereinbarten
Änderungen bei der Miete erst angehen
wenn die SPD Innenministerin die
vereinbarten Änderungen bei der
Vorratsdatenspeicherung angeht eine
Blockade ein weiterer Konflikt um
grundsätzlich ist nun liegen erste Pläne
für morgen auf dem Tisch Clara gaiwitz
will unter anderem neue Hilfen zum Bauch
bereitstellen die Opposition bleibt
skeptisch
es ist schon bezeichnend das wichtige
Akteure wichtige Verbände trotzdem der
Bundeskanzler eingeladen hat sagen sie
nehmen gar nicht erst teilt das zeigt
eben das Vertrauen in die
Bundesregierung und das Vertrauen auch
in die Führungskraft von Bundeskanzler
stolz dass es offensichtlich nicht mehr
da für die Branche ist es morgen ein
echter Schicksalstag aber auch für die
Gesellschaft die Wohnungsnot ist sozial
verheerend fraglich ob das Krisentreffen
im Kanzleramt Abhilfe schafft
und zugeschaltet ist uns jetzt der
Generalsekretär der Partei die im
Wahlkampf 400.000 neue Wohnungen pro
Jahr versprochen hat und der das auch im
Koalitionsvertrag verantwortlich
verhandelt hat guten Abend Kevin Kühnert
einen schönen guten Abend Herr Kohl
morgen also baugipfel im Kanzleramt es
fehlen 700.000 Wohnungen im Land die
Erkenntnis ist ja eigentlich nicht neu
warum haben Kanzler und SPD
bauministerin nicht längst den Turbo
eingelegt
zum Zeitpunkt als wir die 400.000
ausgegeben haben ist das Marktumfeld ein
deutlich besseres gewesen dass es nun
anders ist kann die Politik allein nicht
ändern das fordert uns nun also heraus
unserer Anstrengung im Bereich Förderung
aber auch Bürokratieabbau zu verstärken
das macht die bauministerin mit dem
wohnungsbündnis was sie im letzten Jahr
gegründet hat und was sich nun morgen
beim Bundeskanzler treffen wird und die
Zahl die wir da ausgeben die 400.000 das
ist die schlichte Notwendigkeit im Land
das wäre absurd wenn die Politik eine
niedrige Zahl ansetzen würde wir würden
den Menschen dann keinen reinen Wein
einschränken denn wir würden behaupten
dass es mit weniger Wohnungen geht als
es tatsächlich notwendig ist die Zahlen
haben sie eben genannt also wir halten
an diesen Zahlen fest und verstärken
unsere Anstrengung immer weiter bis es
klappt Frau david hat ja schon erste
Andeutungen gemacht wird jetzt das GG
noch mal verändert also erstmal nur
Klima Maßnahmen für öffentliche Gebäude
zunächst mal hat sie noch eine andere
Ankündigung gemacht über die wir uns in
der SPD auch sehr freuen nämlich dass
die Eigentumsförderung die wir neu
aufgelegt haben für Familien die sich
die eigenen vier Wände leisten wollen
dass die einfacher zugänglich werden
wird da gelten im Moment
Einkommensgrenzen von 60.000 € im Jahr
um diese Förderung kriegen zu können das
wird jetzt deutlich hochgehen und das
ist ein ganz wichtiger Punkt um den
Traum von den eigenen vier Ländern
möglichen zu können und zurück zu meiner
Frage
wird das GEG noch mal verändert
es habe ich akustisch nicht verstanden
Entschuldigung
noch mal aufgemacht und verändert sie
hat ja gesagt sie will erstmal die
bestimmte klimamaßnahmen nur für
öffentliche Gebäude haben
das ist eine Forderung die wir in der
SPD jetzt schon eine ganze Weile heben
und ich bin mir sicher dass da in den
nächsten Tagen auch Bewegung reinkommen
wird wer mit dem heizungsgesetz jetzt
zum Bereich der klimaeffizienz im
Gebäude Sektor eine wichtige
Entscheidung getroffen Maßnahmen darüber
hinaus sollten wir erstmal auf
öffentliche Gebäude fokussieren und
jetzt nicht noch höhere in Effizienz
Standards an den Neubau ansetzen genauso
ist es mir wichtig an dieser Stelle zu
sagen dass für die SPD klar ist dass wir
Dinge wie ein sanierungszwang oder
ähnliches was manche Ort diskutiert wird
definitiv nicht mittragen werden ich
glaube jetzt ist erstmal genug reguliert
in diesem Bereich und das klar zu sagen
aber offensichtlich waren die bisherigen
Maßnahmen ja nicht ausreichend der
Gesamtverband der Wohnungswirtschaft der
spricht mit Blick auf die Politik viel
mehr von
wahrnehmungsverweigerung und das nach
fast zwei Jahren Ampel versprechen
ja der GdW das ist der Verband von dem
sie gerade sprechen der nimmt nun morgen
nicht an dem Treffen teil ist damit in
der klaren Minderheit die meisten werden
vor Ort sein und ich glaube da muss
jeder Verband dann noch ein bisschen für
sich selbst entscheiden wie der die
Interessen seiner Mitglieder gut
vertreten möchte die meisten tun das
indem sie am Tisch sitzen vom Deutschen
Mieterbund bis hin zur Bauindustrie und
zum Bauhandwerk die werden alle morgen
da sein und übrigens verhandeln wir
morgen auch über ganz wichtige Punkte
die beispielsweise Herr gitaschke und
der GdW immer wieder aufgebracht haben
nämlich darüber ob z.B eine besondere
Tempo Förderung für effiziente Heizungen
aber die wir im Gebäude Energiegesetz
ermöglicht haben
der fehlende Verband das sei nur
angemerkt verdreht den größten Teil der
Industrie aber selbst ihre eigenen SPD
Abgeordneter Kreises machen ja jetzt
Druck und fordern eine Trendwende und
mehr Tempo in der Wohnungspolitik
beispielsweise durch weniger
Bauvorschriften und schnellere
Genehmigung das heißt doch ihre eigene
Fraktion ist unzufrieden mit der SPD
Ministerin
nein sondern die eigene Fraktion
unterstützt die Ministerin genau in dem
was sie tut Klara geibitz hat das
Bündnis zusammengeholt damit bauen
einfacher wird und der Bundeskanzler hat
sein diesem Wochenende noch mal
unterstrichen es ist doch absurd wir
haben 16 Landesbauordnung in Deutschland
und in der Theorie bekennen sich die
Länder dazu dass sie einfacher bauen
wollen aber in der Praxis kommen wir
nicht voran die Leittragenden sind zum
Beispiel viele Wohnungsbauunternehmen
die gerne seriell nach Typen Genehmigung
bauen würden immer wieder dasselbe
wohnungsmodell an unterschiedlichen
Orten das erschweren wir unnötig im
Moment und genau das wollen wir
vereinfachen das ist im Interesse vieler
die dort morgen mit am Tisch sitzen und
übrigens wenn man mit
Wohnungsunternehmen spricht hört man
auch viele die sich von ihren
verbandsspitzen dort im Moment nicht
vertreten fühlen und die durchaus dafür
sind jetzt zu sprechen und zu
Kompromissen zu kommen denn nur so
kann's gehen können herzlichen Dank für
das Gespräch
ich danke Ihnen